you may think you know why fortnight is
the most popular game in the world but
you're probably wrong
sure fortnight is the most mechanically
sound Battle Royale game and it's
accessible to a younger audience who
mostly plays on console but what you
don't know is that Epic Games has gone
there audience to be constantly thinking
constantly theorizing about fortnight's
and many mysteries they've captured an
entire generation of gamers with an
experience they've never really had
before they've given the mysteries to
solve and secrets to uncover at a rate
that no other game can match it's
something no other game has ever really
attempted before if only because the
internet would spoil most of the secrets
before they could even be hidden so
fortnight is the most popular game on
earth played by everyone from your
cousin to drink but the secret to for
tonight's popularity isn't that
celebrities are playing it the trick is
that it has an engaged audience of young
fans who keep coming back every season
epic games works more weird new
mysteries into their game and despite
the internet existing to document every
new piece of information there's still a
sense of mystery and wonder of a
fortnight and what's more amazing than
anything about that is that they've
almost perfectly recreated the feeling
of playing video games in the 90s of
sharing theories with friends and
looking for secrets that might not even
be there all given to a new generation
of players who never had a way to
experience that for example 4/9 season 5
launched put in plenty of new Easter
eggs for fans to puzzle over there's a
golf course a racetrack randomized moai
heads and even a Viking ship dropped on
the map as part of the rifts opening up
and dropping things into the game
meanwhile previous season saw a meteor
hanging overhead that eventually crashed
into the map and changed the game world
creating dusty divot pop rocks and an I
invincible ice cream truck
[Music]
boertie has been doing stuff like this
for months now and I think it's really
hard to pretend like this isn't a big
part of its success instead of focusing
on adding new map support night the way
that pub G has gone for night has
instead chosen to update its map adding
new secrets and easter eggs for fans to
look for and on top of that they've even
started hiding things in the real world
as part of a complicated and still
unfinished ultimate reality game or Arg
[Applause]
so why is this making the game popular
well to understand that we have to go
all the way back to the earliest days of
console gaming video game designers have
been hiding secrets or Easter eggs in
their games for decades going all the
way back to adventure for the Atari 2600
released in 1980 and games have followed
that example even years later just look
at call of duty black ops 3 which hid a
secret zombie attack in nuke town
[Music]
but a lot of these modern Easter eggs
are pretty well documented along with
their equal opposites secrets that don't
actually exist see in the 80s 90s even
the early 2000 most of the information
you were getting about video games was
from magazines or other kids on the
playground and kids just like to make
[ __ ] up look if the rumor that mu was
hidden under a truck in pokemon red and
blue
[Music]
or the quest to find the Triforce in the
Legend of Zelda Ocarina of Time
neither thing was actually hidden in
those games but it didn't stop idiot
kids like me who didn't have any
information from spending hours trying
to find them that's because we didn't
really have the Internet and what little
access we did have to the nascent
Internet was full of misinformation and
allies just ask people who believed
Shang long was a real dude or that Sonic
was in melee but as you know they became
more organized it was easier to separate
truth from lies but people still wanted
to think and see your eyes about these
games constantly so marketing companies
took advantage of that and started
creating a RGS which when it comes to
video games tend to be marketing
campaigns that bleed the games into the
real world a great example is I love
bees a popular energy used to advertise
Halo 2
ILB started off as a website about
beekeeping that was slowly hacked to
reveal codes that led players to pay
phones in the real world that embroiled
players in a plot that made them part of
Kalos Canada clears who made it all the
way to the end also got an early chance
to play Halo 2 so how do decade old
marketing tricks and dusty internet
rumors relate back to fortnight well for
tonight's marketing strategy and a world
development or a walk from boat over the
past few months Epic Games has been
constantly updating for a nice match it
doesn't happen every update but it is
happening consistently for example
before the meteor dropped plenty of fans
had their own theories about what it
would do to the map some rights the
meteorite will not be hitting til two
towers and will in fact be hitting dusty
Depot instead some not so right April
31st would be May first which is the
start of the fourth season which means
tilt the towers is getting heated on May
1st then as a rocket began to launch
into the sky during season four more
theories came out the world of fortnight
was in a dome and was being protected
protected from the outside world the
other universe has been this led to
rifts in the sky which of course led to
more theory I've seen a circulating
theory going
so that is what I'd like to share with
you guys today the entire 4/9 map and
the battle royale game is actually a
simulation and now things have started
coming through the rifts things that
might be from far away
meanwhile epic games picked off an Arg
ahead of seasons 5 that softens tracking
down various fortnight objects in our
world it started with a person finding
the der burgers mascot in the middle of
a desert in California after the burger
itself vanished from the game map after
that a bunch of people showed up at that
location and handed out phone numbers
that when called would give players of
code that led back to the in-game der
burger location around the same time
people started spotting such high llamas
all around Europe and while their
purpose is still unclear that didn't
stop anyone from speculating maybe
there's an IRL challenge it is also
heavily thought out to be this next big
thing that what you're going to find is
the tomato head all of this put together
came to a pretty interesting picture all
of the information about fortnight is
there on the Internet it's not a
particularly complicated game and it's
not like they've been involved plot the
map is the only thing players really
have as an anchor point to fortnight's
world by changing it and teasing out in
those changes slowly with both in-game
secrets and out of game Arg s epic has
gone people to think about their game
constantly and not just that they're
thinking about it in the way that kids
you used to think about games before the
Internet one of the reasons they can do
that is because epic games spent years
making an engine that allowed them to
iterate their game faster than nearly
anything else on the market what we
think is our critical success is our
ability to make just gameplay impactful
and just constantly improving the player
experience built to build a week to week
changes in fortnight are measured in
weeks not months not years
compare that to pub G which has been
much slower to implement updates part of
that is that epic has far more people
working on fortnight than of G Corp has
working on their game but let's look at
an even bigger project World of Warcraft
Blizzard maintains an enormous team to
run that game and well I don't want to
pretend like I know everything about
their engine and development process it
takes a while for Blizzard to make
changes to wow there's even some content
that's more than a decade old that's
never been changed epic and fortnight by
extension news faster than nearly any
other game of the market which means the
secrets that you find in the game today
might not be there tomorrow and then
they're the secrets that move around the
map like the randomly spawning moai head
said always carry gold treasure
that means that players are incentivized
to hunt for secrets and talk about them
and as they disappear it money's the
truth of it all just like it was
internet rumors from back in the day the
one thing that I am almost 100% sure
will be coming through is going to be an
egyptian-themed area and I am almost
also certain that this is going to be
happening right around loot Lake we can
see this current anomaly appearing
through the water fortnight has created
a culture of fans who speculate about
the game discuss their theories and then
head out both into the game in the real
world to find more things to theorize
about while other game designers are
trying to copy fortnight's mechanics or
cartoony aesthetics looking for the next
big hit maybe the trick isn't
replicating the way that fortnight has
players looking for and thinking about
mysteries and an era where games just
don't have those anymore thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button